that's the prevention arm of health
services and it's public health that
often ends up at the bottom of the queue
is funding decisions and we need to look
at the whole system the NHS social care
and public health altogether and take a
long term viewers as well as address the
here-and-now
not sure what point there though really
that and and I have to ask you because
you're the you know the MP or the
politician on the panel it's it's a
nettle the politicians seem loath to
grasp when it comes to to root and
branch reorganization perhaps maybe that
has been driver getting on to of course
what the Health Service doesn't need is
a massive organizational churn what it
needs is some stability but as I say
what we do need to get better at is
planning for the long term not just for
the funding but also for our workforce
and thinking about where we can invest
the money most effectively to get the
best for patients and come back to
patients and what they need
okay Helen's coach Lampard I mean with
that celebration yeah longer life
expectancy nevertheless then the creeks
the strains are really beginning to show
that well they are because for all the
reasons articulated and actually health
and how health is determined is much
wider than health care and social care
and the public health it's it's
education it's the account economics of
a society and it's all those things
together so we can focus tonight on the
NHS and that's right and proper on the
Eva at 70th birthday but actually we do
need to look at health in the wider
sense when we look about people's
well-being and Sonia mentioned about
unhealthy living about you know so many
of the diseases of our modern society
are related to the lifestyles we lead
and so you know and society can has a
part to play here this isn't just about
the NHS getting its house in order this
is a wider thing too we need to think
about that as well David Nicholson I
write for the beginning I would say that
I think the private sector can help us
in lots of ways in the NHS and does help
us in lots of ways in the NHS but it
over politicize that well the issue for
me very often is it's about the values
who drive these organisations about the
right values but can I just raise the
issue about I think chawl mentioned
taxpayers bailing out the NHS in some in
some way the thing about we have to
understand is that health expenditure is
a really good thing
anomaly it's a really powerful thing
it's one of the best ways that you can
improve economic growth in your in your
society public expenditure on health
care generally speaking get spent in
this country with people who work in
this country so it's a really powerful
way of driving the economy so we
shouldn't protect you know shouldn't get
ourselves into a place that somehow
health in you know health expenditure is
something we need to avoid or is is
difficult we need to make sure that
there has to be a limit to it there is a
limit to how much the nation can afford
of course there is and I have to say
I've worked in you know a large number
of countries over the last four or five
years and there isn't a country in the
world who sat there at the moment
thinking we've got it all sorted we've
got enough money in our healthcare
system we're doing everything but we
need to do so this kind of tension and
pressure is a necessary part of
delivering a health care health care
system and the other thing I'd say is
that there is a there's a slight issue
here about public sector bad private
sector good and all I would say is that
in terms of labor productivity labor
pontifical in the health service over
the last seven or eight years has been
remarkable it's grown at a very high
rate in fact if labor productivity in
the rest of the economy had grown at the
rate that he has in the health service
we'd have paid off the whole deficit
into the country and we sat on a pile of
money so industry should follow other
people can look I just saw on at that
point that David was making I mean do
you think that you know private sector
bad public sector good no I don't I
think that's weighty simplistic I don't
think that I wouldn't like to see 50
percent of NHS services delivered by the
private sector I think don't change the
feel of the NHS but I think where
there's a very strong case that the
private sector can add things great the
one word of caution would be is that the
state has got a history of writing some
pretty bad contracts with the private
sector just look at PFI deals with
hospitals for example that that led to
the building of new hospitals so it's
definitely not the case private sector
good public sector bad either I think we
have to take a very pragmatic view about
things as they come up and Sean this
issue of
spending being a burden that David's
pointing out it's not a burden there are
huge benefits from it for for society as
a whole it's no it's not of course it is
is fantastic but I think there is a
reasonable argument to say that if you
look at the trajectory of how much
spending has to go up to meet the demand
of the NHS by it is going to get bigger
if we are going to be you and I are
going to be paying more in income tax to
fund the kind of NHS that we want and I
think most of us probably accept that
but there's got to be a we've got to
have more than that we've got to have
new ideas new technology we've got
embrace change
we've got embrace innovation and nothing
should be taken away from the NHS I'm
arguing that more should be put into it
but it doesn't have to all be money okay
well just laying out the groundwork at
the moment would get much more into
funding in a moment or two but I want to
ask you Lord does he and this is this is
the c-word and it is crisis now as long
as I've been in journalism which is more
years and I want to remember we've been
talking about a crisis in the NHS is
that one from your point of view it's
challenging Robin its crisis it depends
how dramatic you want to be journalists
that are describing is a crisis but yeah
I mean it seems the general public a big
huge huge huge pressure within the
system I work in one of hospital like
this across the river at Samaras
Hospital and we can feel that on a daily
basis we have staff shortages we have a
huge growing demand in the A&E we have
issues in admitting patients for
elective surgery so there are challenges
but the system is coping the one thing
Majesty I've just on a recent review
with IPPR
and I looked at the quality and the
outcomes of care now than 10 years ago
when I was in office and I led a major
review and I could confidently tell you
that the quality and the outcome of care
today is significantly better than when
I was a minister that's a fantastic news
so despite all the crises whatever you
hear in the papers cancer outcomes are
better there's a 5% improvement in
survival in one year there is tremendous
improvements in cardiovascular disease
I'm not saying it's weird um there's a
long way to go but it is much better
what is challenging is what we call
access getting into the system yeah well
there's primary care
or Hospital once you get into the system
you'll be arrested you're going to get a
good quality care well a lot of thoughts
on that I can hear from the panel beside
me but we'll get on to those in a moment
or two because the Lord ours you touched
on the issue there of outcomes which
leads us nicely into our next session
when we will hear from advocates but I
want to remind you all first off though
that the end of tonight's debate our
studio audience here at Guy's Hospital
will be voting on what they've heard
they are listening intently in choosing
whether more public money this key
question where the more public money or
more private investment is the best way
to secure the future of the NHS is that
argument develops throughout the course
of the evening but now I want to focus a
bit more on that issue that Lord as he
mentioned there that surely resonates
most with everyone involved in the NHS
patients and staff alike that is the
care that it provides and the outcomes
first at this time is Sean Worth Sean
thank you very much so we've talked
about NHS being in in crisis social care
is a massive problem and I promise you
having worked in politics in opposition
and in government no politician will
want to be straight with you about this
problem all want to talk about it with
you on that that's the unfortunate truth
again we've got a huge problem the
social care system is not funded
publicly is a mix of private investment
in everything else the only thing I
would say to this is there is literally
and conceivable that we tack on an
ageing population with huge social care
needs to the taxpayer bill of younger
generations it's not going to work no
serious economist has even looked at
this and said that that's going to work
you shouldn't have to pay for it the the
big thing that needs to happen is that
the the generation most in need of care
is actually the wealthiest that has ever
lived in this country they're setting on
a trillion and half pounds of housing
equity is a controversial proposition
sometimes but I believe that people
should take the responsibility to
release some of that wealth that they
have to pay for their for their social
care needs in in in order to protect
younger generations from having to pick
up the bill so that they can have the
opportunities that they have but so that
it's fair just to finish so that it's
there and and some people don't face
catastrophic costs and others you know
by good fortune you don't have any there
should be an insurance pooling system
which the which unfortunately the market
cannot provide because it can't it can't
cater with the the extreme risks at some
ends of population the government should
step in and help to create that but
people unfortunately will have to take
more responsibility for for Social Care
in later life rather than putting that
burden onto their children okay
insurance funding for Social Care with
an initial investment from the
government Sonia what do you think I
completely disagree with Sean so I think
there's a really important principle
enshrined in the NHS and it's not just
that the affluent pay more than the poor
through their taxes for care it's also
that the sick don't pay more than the
well and if you look at cancer care if
you get sick your costs are covered at
the moment if you if you're unlucky
enough to get dementia your costs aren't
covered unless you don't have very many
assets and I think that's incredibly
inequitable why should we apply that
principle of if you're sick you don't
pay pay more than the unhealthy then the
well rather in the NHS but not in Social
Care and I think that distinction
creates all sorts of problems in the
system we don't even save enough for our
retirements for the healthy period of
living when older let alone the
miserable prospect of spending a few
years in a care home in the run-up to
our death people are always going to
under spend on Social Care that's always
going to keep pressure on the NHS so I
think we need to fund social care on the
same basis as the NHS it's time for a
1948 style settlement not for the NHS
but we need to extend it to social care
now you might say gosh how do we pay for
it well we're a rich society we can
afford it of course we should ask the
baby boomer generation to contribute
more but that should come through
progressive taxation so that those who
are unlucky enough to get dementia don't
end up paying more than those who are
lucky enough to live well till the end
of their lives and the final note that
I'll end on is I complete completely
agree with Lord ours either
extending lifespans
an amazing scientific achievement that
should be celebrated but the fact is at
the moment they do come with a price tag
until we discover that elixir that
allows us to like live in perfect health
and who we reach our destiny we have to
be prepared to meet them as a society
otherwise quite frankly the consequences
are unpalatable for our mums our dad's
our elderly relatives so this is a cost
we can afford to bear economists have
actually looked at it a very prominent
economist did a review for the King's
fund back in 2010 and concluded that it
was possible as long as we're
politicians are brave and say we did
this for the NHS in 1948 we're going to
do it for older people here and now in
2018 and I think they can do it ok well
I'm going to come to a sarah Wollaston
on that in a moment or two but Helen you
are nodding along there and give me it
from the perspective of GPS this dilemma
they're really rather caught in the
crossfire in all this aren't they more
and more in particular elderly people
coming along seeing their GP and
cheapies not knowing what to do with
them where the hospitals are full and
the social care system a mess is a
really simple metaphor that people's
lives are their physical situation their
social situation in their psychological
situations when they walk through my
door I'm interested in their medical
problems but also where they live how
they live in the care they have matters
too and also their psychological
elements but you can look at another
three elements which other primary care
sectors of general practice in the first
point of contact care the secondary care
sector the Lord Ozzy represents in the
hospital David has and also the social
care element and if one of those is out
of balance the pressure on the others is
completely untenable so we have to get
our Social Care embraced into this like
absolutely agree with Sonia I mean it's
a really bold proposition I like it I
like it a lot and I'd love to know how
we could work it but actually we do have
to have them in equipoise because it
puts the rest of the system under strain
general practice huge strain at the
moment unprecedented well is it a mess I
mean have you seen areas do you know of
places where it actually works in the
manner you described where it is joined
up well you can yes there are some
really bold adventures happening out
this you've got places like Manchester
who are taking a bigger picture view of
health and social care and well-being
and getting education involved in local
government in
and it's a big experiment at the moment
but we're watching closely because it
could have lessons for all of us for my
point today with the bit I know best is
general practice and we're desperately
short of GPS we're probably about a GP
short of every practice in the country
and that's the harsh reality of it so
when the patients come through the door
not only are they struggling to fix
struggling to get the appointment and
when they come and see us and we try and
do our stuff and our best for them we've
got nowhere to send them we've got with
we're compensating for the social care
sector we're compensating for the fact
they've had their operations turned down
that they can't get an appointment it's
a year to see a specialist and we're
firefighting and that's not right we
need we can do better
well I'm keen to get to Sarah or on
those some of those funding models in a
moment or two but David Nichols never
thought because I want to hear from you
on they saw on the best practice and I
know the NHS for many many years has
been observing an encouraging best
practice and carrying out a experiments
and tests it doesn't seem to spread
though it doesn't seem to get joined up
if you find somewhere where it does work
it doesn't move on this is not unusual
in health care health care change in
health care is really tough to do
anywhere in the world that people will
will tell you that partly it's because
we've got a very educated and discerning
workforce who don't want to just be told
what to do they want to discover
themselves work out outer to do it to
make the connections themselves to make
it happen and sometimes that takes time
and in a strange kind of way by trying
to rush some of this stuff we've
actually slowed it down there are all
sorts of ways in which we can make it
happen in in different countries have
tried different different method but at
least we have a healthcare system which
enables it to happen
most other countries don't even have a
system that can work like that okay
we're going to get on to reorganization
in a moment or two in our next section
you touched on that it's all going to
crossover of course it isn't
particularly at the center of it all
this issue of funding and there we had
it encapsulated Sarah Wallace turn there
well you know it's on you so the same
for for all the problems we can afford
it we're a rich nation sure let's bring
in some money from those that that
campaign this of course was element of
that we're in the conservative manifesto
in the last election and look how that
we we can pay but we do need to level
with people about how that's going to be
funded I'd be delighted there's a brexit
dividend I don't happen to think that's
going to happen we can't depend on it
what we need to do is level with people
about how we can bring it in and of
course there are things the government
can do about adjusting for example
whether they cancel plan changes to
things like corporation tax and tax
thresholds we can grow the economy but
we also need to actually say to people
are you going to be prepared to pay more
and we need to do that fairly across the
generations we can do it we know that
they provide pre personal care in
Scotland for example and it produces
savings to the whole system because if
Social Care fails people end up in much
more expensive settings in hospital so
it's the right thing to do and it also
protects people from catastrophic care
costs and my committee worked with the
Citizens jury alongside another
cross-party Select Committee and the
citizens jury a number of people just
like yourselves in the audience felt
that they wanted to see extra taxation
earmarked for the purpose that it was
intended for and they suggested and we
agreed with them that actually having an
extra premium to national insurance for
example but spread fairly across the
generations they also supported having
an earmarked element to inheritance tax
so we do actually bring in part of that
as well
it's Lib Dem policy for the NHS we've
had a political failure one party brings
up something and another party says it's
a death tax and the next time around we
get told it's a dementia tax we've got
to get to grips with this that's what I
think and I I believe that the public
want to see political parties working
together that's a very good point it's
sorted and we've suggested that well
it's not bring it across the parties
because with your Labour politician hat
or and that that does happen doesn't it
I've witnessed it well you know one
party in power comes up with some kind
of solution for Social Care the other
lot call it a death tax they get into
power
bring it in and the opposition call it a
death tax but let me just start I fully
support Sarah absolutely delighted what
she said let me give you my own example
25 years ago when I started
consultant where I am now I could see a
patient who's an 85 year old and I used
this recent as an example who had a
cancer I wouldn't have operated on this
patient 25 years ago with the
technological advance I can I could do a
keyhole operation wonderful lady
delightful wonderful recovery ready to
go home in 48 hours she's still in
hospital a week later because there is
no social care do you know how much that
cost the NHS 3 billion pounds a year 3
billion pounds of your money that is
equivalent two point three million bed
days a year no surprise we can't get
patients in so there is a negative
impact here and the manifesto of the
Conservative Party law I you know I
thought was a good idea terribly
communicated awful you know it's but
actually i oj go back and see the policy
of it there was something on there and I
think I put all my confidence in the
Select Committee coming up with
something embracing you know stop
playing politics politics with healthy a
socially agreement I've got agreement
here just before we move on I've got to
ask are two advocates though to have
some interchange on this very issue I
mean Shawn could you not live with we
both agree that more money has to go in
you know if the public did support it
could you not live with it coming from
general taxation we are a rich nation as
Sonia says if the public goods photo is
one thing but I mean my argument is
about younger generations actually
because the your what you if you take
sanyas argument you're you're looking at
a problem and you're just pointing at
people and saying you've got a you've
got to pick off up more money and these
are people that don't get free
university education they can't get on
the housing ladder they don't have fun
of salary pensions they don't have the
kind of wealth that that an older
generation that we've got has has
amassed now and I'm just saying in a
progressive society should we not burden
younger generations should we ask those
that need that just to do something more
if they've got the wealth to okay I mean
that's mostly why can you live with that
but a progressive policy and it is true
that one generation seems to have a lot
of the wealth particularly stuffed away
and their house it's yeah the answer is
very simple to Shaun's point you do it
through progressive taxation so you do
it through wealth taxation
like inheritance tax you might look for
example at taxing people in retirement
who have big final salary pension
schemes they don't they paid off their
mortgage they don't need that money so
you do it through targeted taxes but the
big difference between me and Sean is
I'm saying whether you've got dementia
or not if you're older and you're
Asselin you pay into the system I think
we mustn't forget as well there's this
whole stereotype and myth that all the
baby boom boom is a hugely wealthy and
sit on million pound houses that's
absolutely not the case it might be true
in some bits of London it certainly
isn't true in other pip bits you like
Wakefield on there's a real dangerous
argument here about pitting generations
against each other when actually it's
about them working together so in
Germany they talk about the young for
the old the poor the rich for the poor
you know as Social Solidarity that's
what it's that's what it's about that's
most important very interesting point
listen we must move on because there is
so much to consider and what we want to
consider now is how the NHS is organized
how the money is allocated how it's
spelled spent well the Health and Social
Care Act back in 2012 was intended to
reduce bureaucracy but actually made the
system more complex many think so is the
way money is managed fit for purpose on
your soda starts this time please give
us your views I don't know about you but
every time I hear the term
reorganisation it just makes me want to
switch off the NHS has been subjected to
a number of really big organisation
reorganizations over the last 20 or 30
years and I think invariably these are
the pet projects of politicians who come
in want to leave their mark saying hey
we're going to mix things up here and do
things differently and often there's
very very little evidence that a big
structural reorganization is going to do
the thing we all really care about which
is improving the quality of care so
we've had you know purchase of provider
splits scrapping PC tees and replacing
them with CCGs acronyms that really just
make your head hurt and I think we need
our politicians to be much longer term
about the NHS there's no evidence that
doing a wholesale reorganisation in
CAIR there is one big structural issue
that needs fixing and that's the one
that I've already talked about which is
the split between the NHS and Social
Care but that seems to be the one big
structural problem that politicians just
don't want to fix so I think we need to
focus much much more on quality of care
or inspections regime how do we make
sure that staff that see something going
wrong feel able to speak out without
fear of losing their jobs that's the
sort of stuff that improves the quality
of care not Andrew Lansley sitting down
with a flipchart
and redrawing the structure of the NHS
okay sure
well nobody would have designed the NHS
as we currently have it if you had a
fresh start we have a very set for a
system of social care as Sonia said we
have hospitals which is a completely
different system from your GP where you
often go first with your with your first
complaint these services aren't really
that well joined up and there are
efforts now to try and integrate them
more you'll hear the word integration a
lot when you when you hear about
healthcare and and I agree that
structural reorganization is you know I
mean it just switches people off and it
costs a huge amount of money so I just
go back to my original argument the
issue with the NHS is not that it needs
to be shaken up and reorganized and
everything else or you know the the
model changed you know everyone accepts
and likes the way we get free care if we
need it and it's very equitable the
issue is can the NHS keep up with the
demands that we're continually placed on
it and can it embrace change new
technology so I'm saying that it needs
to bring in more expertise from outside
itself not selling bits off not charging
people but allowing the services to be
delivered by many many more different
types of providers some in the private
sector some in social enterprise
charities it's already happening in
small patches but we have a ridiculous
controversial privatization debate which
is completely manufactured and false
which prevents this from happening but
finally the the worst part of this is if
you actually do a poll with ordinary
regular patients and say would it be
reasonable would it be beneficial to try
other providers to deliver your services
and give you a choice of
the vast majority of them say yes and
most interestingly is the poorest who
most want that change because they face
the least choice under the present
system okay thank you both very much
indeed David Nicholson I mean on the
issue of reorganizations you went
through a fair few yourself do they end
up just rearranging the deckchairs well
the first thing to say is the
International evidence is very clear on
this it doesn't make any difference at
all what kind of organization you have
for your health care system in
managerial terms what matters is were
how many doctors nurses I've helped
professionals and with money you spend
on it that's what makes the difference
two to two outcomes and very often in my
experience it's been I think it's
described by a marigold ring it's
messing about masquerading its action so
when we lose the when everything else is
too difficult we reorganize and it's
really dangerous for that for therefore
a system just suicide I was looking at
the Gosport report which is you know
everybody in health care should look at
that and you know a whole lot of things
have been said about it and one of the
things you look when you look at it the
number of different people who were
engaged and involved in the management
of that hospital and the supervision of
that hospital must have changed almost
annually from 2000 you know right the
way through that but it's back that's
back also to the point you were making
about empowerment of the people who work
there all the time in this issue
whistle blows of people speaking out
about bad practices and people speaking
about best practice as well so so where
you start from is you you get people to
work together and they start to tell you
what kind of barriers and obstacles
there are to working in the best
interests of patients and then you build
your organization around that you don't
do the other way around
which is to stand with Andrew Lansley
flipchart it was a very large Fletcher I
have to say I'm a quarry draw draw it
all out that simply won't get you to the
right place
okay well let Sarah Wilson I mean you
know Andrew Lansley Lord Lansley now
he's the man behind it all what were you
thinking at the time is you hearing the
plans coming down the track the Select
Committee very clearly said that we
thought it was overly complex and the
point is that we focus too much on
systems and as David Nicholson says you
know the big question should be does it
make the experience better for patients
or not and the answer is it very rarely
I think that question wasn't
front-and-center it was all the I mean
you know the trouble is that there many
of us said at the time that this was
overly complex in introducing far too
much fragmentation and it would have
been better to have focused on patients
and that unfortunately did not happen
because you know if you look over the
years I used to teach junior doctors and
medical students and I gave up teaching
them about the structure of the NHS
simply because I knew no because it
would have changed by the time they
qualified and and that is the try and
the other thing that we found on the
Select Committee is we have this acronym
spaghetti STPs ECGs you know all these
doesn't think a CS nobody knows what
they mean and and the question we have
to ask is does it make the experience
better for patients and very often that
means focusing at local level getting
people to work better at local level
rather than just having this endless
debate about changing around systems
let's focus on the patient okay I'm
gonna come to you for Helen very very
shortly but Lord Darcy you know with
senior technicians of angle like you
practitioners within the NHS do you get
frustrated by what you see from the
managerial class absolutely you know
when I go to the ward first thing I ask
who's in charge when I treat a patient
the patient and the family says who is
in charge of my care
I say I am there's an accountability
issue as well it's not the structure and
it's not just me it's the nurses that
helped me is the physiotherapist is
looking after the patient is my
communication with the general
practitioner who's gonna take over the
patient when it comes to the community
everyone knows who's in charge if you
look at the landscape nationally there
is NHS see NHS ICQ CPH ehee sounds like
a big newly discovered drug you go out
there and say who's in charge I mean 10
years ago at least
I used to turn around when I was in
office you know who's in charge
Nicholson was in charge yeah and
decision needs to be made
he was the accountable officer now we
have very we need to rebreathe this
align this and I'm delighted to hear
from the Health Select Committee's an
action fact to be fair the prime
minister said recently
if the NHS feels the management the
doctors the nurses the GPS working it
that there would be simplified way of
managing the NHS then it should go to
the selectivity and I'm looking forward
to some form of common sense and
bringing not a doctor but a country but
well just before you come back Sarah
just want to hear from Helen because GP
is obviously a hugely important after
those reforms put right into the the
middle of it all did they get too much
of burden in a way out of all this do
you know we can spend all our time
looking backwards Dermot but where we
are now we need to be looking forwards
with health care as everyone has said we
wouldn't choose to be where we are we
are where we are we need to learn from
the past but let's look forward about
what we can do to improve the current
situation I mean obviously I'm going to
argue for shoring up and supporting
general practice very we are in a
parlous state at the moment we've had
these promises and but we're still
desperately short of people and that's
not just about GPS it's about district
nurses health visitors physios it's the
whole health care team in the community
because we know the most effective and
efficient way of running a health care
system is to invest in your primary care
infrastructure because when we're
functioning well we protect it to people
we save them they don't need to go to
hospital as often if we can do more for
them in the community everybody wins if
the general practice is in a sensible
state Sarah you want to make it quick
last point I want to think that we
recommended on the Health Committee was
that if we're going to make it simpler
and there need to be tweaks to the
legislation please let's have that
designed by the Health Service and
social care and patient groups and then
we will examine their recommendations as
David said there perhaps there's no
point I'll leave it as it is is that
what you are saying leave it as you know
it's been done there's no point it might
not work but leave it as it is and just
let's concentrate on the funding and the
resource well there is no doubt I don't
know whether we're going to talk about
the 3.4% at some stage but we're getting
on key bit of all of that is how do you
turn that into people on the ground as
quickly as you can and you've got a
system which is not designed to do that
so
there is some urgent work needs to be
done okay I would say she'll be driven
by the front line but should concentrate
on simplification that should be at the
end of the day if we can't explain it to
the patient and the public how it works
how on earth it's faith and I thank you
for mentioning the 3.4 percent the 20
billion we're getting closer and closer
to the point of voting on that one last
topic though before we get there before
the audience get to have they say when
they vote on whether more taxation or
more privatization is the best route
forward for the NHS and now I want to
look now at the pressures the future
perhaps the solutions that are coming
down the track as we look to the next 70
years of the NHS sure worth first this
time yes I think I mean look at the
debate tonight I think you can be a
pessimist or an optimist the pessimists
will look at the huge pressures on the
system and think oh goodness we just
have to put our hands in our pockets and
continually pay more and more and more
until essentially we're taxed out of our
pocket there's a positive vision which
says we yes we'll have to put more money
in but we'll have to change as well and
the NHS has to be faster adapting to new
technology new providers new ways of
working all the things that we want to
see the NHS do that patients we know
want to see NHS embrace but doesn't
happen at the moment because basically
because of politicians and the NHS
establishment being resistant to that
change the key i what I'd really love to
see and there's a this links to the
extra funding going into the NHS I would
love to see that funding not being
poured into doing the same old thing the
same you know at the same time there's
money going in and I know it has to fill
some gaps but let's keep some money
aside and create new funds for really
innovative new practices that we from
around the world including new medicines
which are terribly slow to get to the
market from market sorry to the patient
again because we've got this incredibly
complicated system let's get that money
into more innovative services bring new
providers in and new medicines get back
to the frontline that's why I'd really
like to see the future of the NHS okay
Sean thank you very much indeed
Sonia well Sean
about pessimist and optimist and I I
think it's pretty clear who he was
referring to as a pessimist
why would I would characterize it debate
slightly differently though I think it's
a debate between realists and fantasies
and I think the real position is
confronting the extra costs at face the
NHS and say being optimistic about our
capacity as a wealthy society to pay for
it I think there is a lot to be excited
about in terms of the medical
technologies that are coming down the
line it's gonna make are that are going
to make our health better things like
genomics artificial intelligence big
data and I think Shawn's been a bit
unfair on the NHS actually the NHS has
been at the pioneering edge of some of
these technologies like immunization
over the years we just learned yesterday
in fact that the NHS is going to be
pioneering the use of genomic technology
so doctors are going to be able to look
at cancer tumors and try and predict
using the gene DNA in them I think I'm
not an expert to see what treatment they
might respond to you Beth so there's
definitely stuff to be excited about -
words of caution though first is that
this medical technology is expensive
generally it's not really a way of
saving money it's stuff we need to spend
on to improve care to make sure we do
all get to our desperate living really
well and the second is I think sometimes
it's easy to get obsessed with
technology while forgetting some of the
simple and the basic stuff and I talked
about the fact that a big challenge the
NHS is that people have got many more
conditions at a chronic that there are
associated with a lifestyle obesity
drinking too much smoking not doing
enough exercise now there are services
that work in helping us live more
healthily things like stop smoking
services but are big challenges is that
it's become much easier for the
government to cut stop smoking services
say than it is to touch the NHS because
we're very protective of our hospitals
and that means we've seen some of the
services like stop smoking being cut and
that's going to load even more costs on
the future Sonya I'm gonna cut you off
there because guess what we're running
out of time but I got to start I'm going
to throw this a bad guy you start with
Sean first of all because Sean you were
accused thereof perhaps have been being
a pessimist you're not excited enough
about the future of the NHS I'm very
excited by the NHS and I'm certainly not
criticising it is your right it's the
actually of the public sector it's the
biggest user of new technology there is
in the public section so it should be
because it's
biggest public service we've got but you
know you could yeah and I'm not saying
I'm not there's no criticism and it does
a fantastic job what I'm saying is that
we need to add to it we can't we can't
keep it the same and ask the tax alright
I paid the same old fare Sean thanks for
inviting us again throw that back at
Sonia that's all he's saying is you know
bring in some expertise from outside if
it's gonna benefit the NHS but the
reason I implied that he was a fantasist
is that it's it's one to think that you
can do that without more resource
resources on the aren't the only answer
there's no way that just by putting more
money into the NHS it's gonna be the
best service in the world there's other
stuff we have to do but it's an absolute
fantasy to think we already spend a lot
less than our international capacity
competitors or some of our international
competitors on our health system it's a
fantasy to think that if we don't invest
in it properly it's gonna continue to be
a world-class okay right where did the
time go our experts here chomping at the
bit to get there say Lord Lord does the
optimist pessimist about the future 70
years more for the NHS and much more
always optimist I've just told you
doubling life expectancy that's because
of science innovation in technology
absolutely that's the evidence looking
into the next 30 years or 70 years the
examples have been talked about machine
learning for example you know we back in
nineteen in the 1940s we saved Europe
and the Western world on the back of
Alan Turing's work and breaking a code
why can't we break the genome code and
understand cancer and have targeted
treatments we can do that we have the
science in this country we should be
very proud of it it's not an added cost
every pound we spend on health you get
to sell that around the world pounds
back absolutely absolutely you get we do
you know how much the the life sciences
industry brings sixty seven billion
people pawns back to this economy here
so we need to be celebrating that you
know seventy percent of the British
population have smartphones why aren't
we using that in delivering health care
and advice and communication you know
it's all out there we just need to
employ lardons if we are running out of
time David Nicholson I want to come back
to that point you made about 3.4 percent
they extra money going in where we're
talking about resources now and the
future and they're continuing demands
and you mentioned
productivity but isn't it the fact that
we're hearing now from health Chiefs
there isn't much more to go for in
productivity improvements now it is all
about the money but many of the things
that Lord Ozzy was describing improved
productivity and I and I think if you
say if you look around most health care
systems in developed countries are going
through this argument this debate at the
moment there are two things they're all
saying the first thing is that in the
future people will have to take more
control over their own health and their
own healthcare than they do now what you
and we need to help people to do that
and technology is a fantastically
incredible thing to do that you know all
sorts of things we can do that and the
second thing is investing in primary
care those two things right everyone is
thinking and that is I think where they
technology when it comes to GPS I don't
know we're hearing what this year we're
all gonna be able to get an app and book
appointments no early morning phone
calls and pretending it's an emergency
but when we see there are loads of
exciting apps out there and I mean this
this new all-singing all-dancing NHS app
great lovely logical sensible as Lord as
he said you know 70% of people have got
smartphones lovely but actually what we
mustn't do is widen the health
inequalities in our society I worry
about the people who haven't got a
smartphone who can't access the Internet
the people who more than ever need to be
able to turn up at a surgery in their
community with somebody who knows them
and cares for them and understands their
whole because the God do that they're
turning up at A&E departments what
exactly and this is and that doesn't
help anybody we need people to get to
the right place to get the right care
apps lovely and if you want to know some
great apps look at the NHS digital
website there's loads of really fun apps
on they've good health care at Sarah
glass half full or empty oh I'm an
optimist but what I'd say is that the
NHS is greatest asset is its workforce
so let's not forget developing training
and retaining our our workforce across
the whole of health and social care and
if we're going to do something in
digital technology I'd like to see
rather than the Secretary of State
owning your medical records I might see
you owning your medical records and for
you to be able to share them wherever
you go so you're not having to keep
repeating your story and having loads
records lost well I try
it was done very badly and we need to
learn the lessons from how that failed
decades ago and get it right this time
but we got it wrong last time because we
wanted it all controlled still by the
state and we need to put the power back
with you the patient you own your record
and share it with who you like well what
a nice point to end our contributions
from the panel that is the final
contribution in the debate from them but
before the audience gets to vote the
all-important audience vote on who's
made the most compelling case we'll have
a final word from each of our expert
advocates encouraging you to vote for
them and first of all their closing
statement is Sonia soda I presented a
simple case here tonight I think living
longer is something to be celebrated but
there were costs involved with it and if
we don't face up to it we are going to
end up running the NHS into the ground
the arbitrary rationing we seen in the
last year the canceled operations that's
going to get worse and you're going to
see more people opting out and getting
private health insurance that's going to
create a two-tier system with one
standard available for the affluent and
one standard available for everyone else
and particularly those on low incomes
and I think that's going to undermine
the very basis of our taxpayer-funded
universal NHS that is really adored by
the public so I would urge you to vote
for putting more tax payer money and
it's the only way forward ok are we
going to hear something very different
yes we are from sure words so yeah I
don't think money itself is just the
answer we're going to have to pay more
in because we're a growing aging
population fine we will put more money
in but we've got to add more and I think
that at you know the final piece here is
opening then HS up to more private
investment social enterprise charities
come in help deliver these services help
us create new ideas the smartphone apps
we're talking about why not put them on
prescription if people haven't got
smartphones we can embrace change new
ideas we have to think a bit outside the
box money is not the answer
okay right there they are the closing
statements from our advocates those are
the arguments that's the turn of our
audience who've sat and listened very
intently here this evening they have
their say on whether increases in NHS
funding should be paid for out
of heart acts ation in all its forms now
each of you has a voting pod I know
sitting there in your hands if you've
been convinced by Sonia soda's case for
a fully taxpayer-funded NHS it's very
simple press option 1 option 1 for
Sonia's view if you don't agree I think
sure worth is right that the NHS needs
more private investment of whatever kind
to survive choose option 2 let me repeat
it's very simple option 1 if you agree
with Sonya's arguments that it should be
paid for more money for the NHS should
come from general taxation if you think
that the private sector private funding
has a role to play vote number 2 we will
process that very quickly and bring the
results to you all in a moment or two
but if you haven't made your mind up at
home yet there's a lot more information
that I can tell you about the National
Health Service including special reports
analysis an interactive graphics on Sky
News calm you can also join the debate
on social media just use the hashtag NHS
70 and we'll have much more coverage
here on Sky News tomorrow as the NHS
formally marks its 70th birthday
including a special service of
celebration at Westminster Abbey which
just shows the place it has in the
nation's heart but now I think I can
bring you the results of the verdict on
of tonight's debate we have 46 percent
voting YES that is yes to more funding
coming from taxation only 54 percent
saying no now interestingly I want to
compare that with a straw poll a similar
vote we put to our audience before we
came live on air and that compares there
has been a shift in opinion a slight
shift in opinion because when we voted
just before as I say we came on air 39%
said yes to more funding coming from
taxation only that's gone up to 46% so
well done Sonia with your persuasive
arguments and 61% before we before we
came on our 61% thought we should look
at other forms as well that's still a
majority though so well done to you
both Shawna's on you thank you very much
indeed now I get final thoughts on that
result and how the audience changed
their views and thank you very much Adi
for listening so intently from our
panelists this evening we'll just go
down the panel Lord are you surprised
first of all by by the numbers that
support the different options I mean to
be honest there they're more or less
well it's more like very 50 expected to
be more weighted towards general
taxation I would have been because there
was a recent survey nationally which
suggested that 80 percent of people will
like to increase the funding of the NHS
through taxation and that came across
but you know you have different
audiences and different indeed so I did
but what it does tell us though is that
you know there are other ways of raising
money and of course we talked about the
NHS being free of course it's not we we
just all pay for it
we absolutely there is nothing for free
you are paying for the NHS but the only
thing I will add to that how much you
pay for the NHS how much we all pay in
this country compare it with other
countries we do very well it's the most
efficient system if you look at the
outcomes at a national level we do much
better for the amount of money we spend
okay that's Sara Wilson a majority here
forum looking at other ways of getting
money into the National Health Service
and of course one looks just across the
channel and Beyond and some degree of
private insurance past what I think is
interesting though is that that they're
talking about different things Sonya's
talking about how we raise the money
whereas Sean's talking about how we
spend it more efficiently so I think if
we what we really need is a more nuanced
question about the different ways that
you could lever it in because it's not
all going to come through taxation as in
you know there are very many ways that
we can spread that so I think that the
question if you don't mind me saying so
is a little bit too simple
that's television for you feel free it's
free and fair debate well on the numbers
simplistic or or not it does show quite
a split within within views you know
there's
debate available here which is what
we're having a course there is a debate
but I mean I have to say having lived
through some of the privatized bits of
the NHS and see how things have been
tried where private companies have come
in and failed and it's gone wrong and
Sonia did refer to some of the rather
embarrassing failures where things just
happened only the IT project we did yeah
absolutely and I think you know so we
need to absolutely be aware and if we're
going to go this route and we absolutely
have to learn from the past now I'm very
very cautious in general practice it
really hasn't worked terribly well so
I'm have to say I'm on your side Sonia I
really feel that it's from the public
person so brilliant asking you to take
sides but you David are you gonna take
sides well I'm on both was it fifty to
forty
it was 46 54 all right so I won't
mention breakfast it's um it is the most
efficient the most effective way of
raising money general taxation you know
throughout the world if you just think
in the United States it they spend 500
billion dollars collecting the money
before they can give it out five hundred
billion dollars what a waste
and not any of that you spent on Direct
ation okay that's all
and it's bet it cost us almost nothing
David thank you very much indeed and
that's it for this special debate about
an institution with a a special place in
British society our thanks of course to
guys Hospital for putting up with us
thanks to to our contributors they are
some of your soda Sean worth Sir David
Nicholson professor Helen Stokes Lampard
Lord Darcy and dr. Cheryl Walston MP and
thank you to our voting audience here
and to you at home for watching from all
of us here at Guy's Hospital a very good
night
[Music]